All right. That just about wraps it up.
I hope you enjoyed the course.
We certainly enjoyed putting it together for you.
Before we sign off, I want do to a few thank yous.
I want to thank Sebastian Thrun for inviting me to do the course
and for giving me this opportunity.
I want to thank the smart and energetic staff at Udacity who provided
support of various kinds in creating and delivering the course.
And I'll single out Katie, Kathleen, Clark, Calvin, and Grant.
Grant, I guess, couldn't manage to get a K on the front of his name. We'll call him Krant.
All of whom were just a delight to work with.
Thanks also to Mor Naaman, a professor at Rutgers,
who gave me some hints about how to gather social network data,
and of course the experts who participated in my interviews,
Andrew Goldberg, Vukosi Marivate, Duncan Watts, Peter Winkler, and Tina Eliassi-Rad.
They graciously shared their time and their knowledge in their interviews.
A big thanks to Eliot Escher, who gave me feedback on my vocal performance
in the song and also contributed her own beautiful voice to the music video.
You can probably figure out which one was her.
I want to thank David Evans at Udacity for providing very detailed feedback
on my lecture notes to make this as Udacity-ish as possible,
even though this was my very first time.
I want to thank my family for putting up with this extra drain on my time,
and finally, thanks to the class T.A. Job Evers,
who made the course happen day after day.
So, good luck to all of you on the final.
It's been a great experience for me, and I hope to see you around.